Simon Kinberg isn't afraid to admit his
mistakes the director of Dark Phoenix
did just that when speaking to KCRW
during an appearance on the outlets the
business podcast getting remarkably
candid the filmmaker took the blame for
everything that went wrong with Dark
Phoenix I'm here and I'm saying what a
movie doesn't work put on me like I'm
the writer director the movie the movie
can connect with audiences that's on me
in the interview Ken Berg noted that
it's difficult to talk about Dark
Phoenix in a negative context because he
genuinely loves the film ultimately
though he feels the onus is on him to
take the blame for Dark Phoenix crashing
and burning with moviegoers and critics
as for what might have saved Dark
Phoenix from its grim fate Kinberg
doesn't believe that there's anything
that could have been done to yield a
different outcome we're changing the
film's release date yet again have
helped it probably not but Kinberg
admitted that the changing dates didn't
help the film land on the right foot I
always felt that we had a tough date for
this particular movie it wasn't made as
a classic superhero movie it was made as
more of a dramatic intimate smaller film
originally it was going to come out
November 2018 then it was going to come
out in February 2000 19:00 and those
were the dates that I felt like it
actually would have felt more
appropriate to did the massive
box-office success of Avengers endgame
now the most profitable film of all time
somehow impact dark Phoenix's
performance when it opened June 7th
maybe but kins burg just can't get
behind the idea that another film is to
blame for dark Phoenix's bombing the
director said coming out five six weeks
after what may well be the biggest movie
or the second biggest movie in the
history of cinema that also happens to
be also in the genre of superheroes was
too tough for us and I always
anticipated that it was going to be
tough to be in the Tailwind of that
movie but I wouldn't blame it on the
weekend the tense atmosphere behind the
scenes at Fox following their merger
with Disney didn't make production on
Dark Phoenix easy either
apparently the layoffs taking place at
that time affected several of the
studio's important arms Kinberg
continued the marketing and publicity
Saida Fox were very badly hit and I
noticed it because I was going to
marketing meetings every week and there
were people who weren't there anymore
Ken Berg also shared that he's actively
trying to keep himself from thinking
about how differently Dark Phoenix may
have fared if it wasn't a lead or if it
had been better marketed at the end of
the day it doesn't matter what happened
happened and Ken burgers taking it as a
learning experience
I mean honestly there's no way to know
and that's the thing that I think can
drive people crazy and keep them up and
be
thinking about a movies failure years
later if the lesson you've learned is
that you have the wrong date or you
didn't have good marketing that's not a
lesson converts comments here are
refreshing it's not often that the
architect of a box-office bomb comes
forward and admits that he should
shoulder part of the blame for a film's
failure what's even more important here
as Ken Burns mentioned that Dark Phoenix
floundering taught him a lesson
the film will probably do the same for
the filmmakers at Marvel Studios who
will be looking to bring x-men and
several other comic-book characters to
the Marvel Cinematic Universe and
working out the best way to introduce
the mutants and a whole new movie
franchise Marvel can turn the Dark
Phoenix and pinpoint the exact things
not to do check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite movies are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]